So, welcome to this session about hypoxia-inducible
factor, HIF, targeting and biology.
There's actually a lot going on in kidney cancer, so I think this is a timely
session. Appreciate you all coming.
I have the who's who of HIF biology and clinical
application to my left here. So Jim Berggren from UT Southwestern, leads their
kidney cancer program and has been a leader in HIF biology for decades, really.
And then Eric Jonash from MD Anderson, who did a lot of the seminal work for
HIF inhibition in VHL syndrome, and he'll present that data.
And then I'm going to talk about sporadic kidney cancer and the clinical
application. So we'll go ahead and kick off.
Jim, if you want to go first, we're excited to hear your talk.
All right.
So, welcome everybody,
and thanks for coming. This is the last day, right
before the plenary,
in the farthest corner of the conference center, so I'm glad you guys
figured out a way to make it.
All right. If I can have my slides. Let's see, this is not
advancing.
The only thing that is moving is the timer.
We'll give you a minute back.
We don't have control up here.
We don't have control of the slides.
There we go.
All right. Maybe I can go to the first slide?
Okay.
There we go. All right. So welcome, everybody.
So I'm going to tell you a very exciting journey, which is an unusual
journey because it's an academic journey, going from the discovery of a gene to a
drug that is now FDA approved for three different indications.
Please consider my disclosures.
So as you probably all know, kidney cancer is expected to
be diagnosed in about half a million people worldwide.
Most common type is clear cell renal cell carcinoma, predominantly affects men.
In about 30% of the patients,
it results in metastasis.
And kidney cancer is one of these tumor types that can metastasize pretty
much to every organ. Some of them associated with poor prognosis, some of
them, when it metastasizes to the pancreas, with better prognosis.
This is something that you may be very familiar with.
So it's a cartoon from the "New England Journal of Medicine." Very simple cartoon,
but makes the point about HIF in clear cell renal
cell carcinoma. It plays a critical role downstream of VHL.
And as you know, this paper was recognized with the Nobel Prize in 2019.
It also outlines the different targeted therapies that we have available for
the field.
A HIF2 inhibitor would not only block angiogenesis, but it would also target cell
proliferation,
block pluripotency, and induce apoptosis.
And today, we're talking about bel sutifan, which is a first-in-class
inhibitor targeting HIF-2 alpha.
So HIF-2 alpha was discovered by four different groups including Steve
McKnight, depicted here, who was at the time the chair of
biochemistry at UT Southwestern, and named HIF-2 alpha EH-PAS one, and
this was in 1996.
Subsequent studies at UT Southwestern by Greg Broek and Kevin Gardner
of the PAS-B domain. So the PAS-B domain, as you can see here,
is one of these two domains, the PAS-A and PAS-B, that are important for
dimerization. The HIF-2 transcription factor is a basic
helix-loop-helix heterodimer, here binds the
hypoxia response element. And these two complex
predominantly interact through the PAS-B domain.
So Kevin characterized the structure, and they
were surprised by the identification of a small cavity, depicted here,
within the PAS-B domain of HIF-2 alpha.
And it's unusual for proteins to have an internal cavity, as you can see
depicted here, with water molecules.
So this led them to hypothesize that this could be exploited for drug
development, and they screened the library of compounds that we
have at UT Southwestern, 200,000 compounds, looking for compounds that
were able to engage the cavity and dissociate the purified PAS-B
domain of HIF-2 alpha and HIF-1 beta.
So that led to identification of several lead compounds that were able to
induce an allosteric change in the PAS-B domain to trigger the
dissociation of these purified PAS-B domains.
Which they subsequently show, were able to dissociate the full complex.
So this led Steve McKnight to found a company, Peloton
Therapeutics, in the UT Southwestern Biocenter, so across the street from UT
Southwestern.
So Peloton Therapeutics
leveraged these insights to develop several inhibitors,
and I'm going to talk to you today about three of them.
So you have this one over here, PT-2385. This is the first in human.
PT-2399, this is the tool compound.
And then PT-2977, this was renamed bel sutifan by
Merck. And as you can see, the overall structure of these
compounds is similar.
So to ask whether these compounds would have activity against kidney
cancer, we leverage our tumor graft platform.
So these are patient tumors implanted in mice, and Bill Kelen
was doing these experiments in cell lines.
So over the course of the years, we have implanted tumors.
Now we are, in fact,
over 2,000 samples
from about the same number of patients orthotopically in mice.
And these tumors are implanted without any additives or
disaggregation, and we've used them for a variety of applications.
So we use this platform. I'm just showing here an example of a tumor
that was treated with vehicle sunitinib to match human
exposures here in green, and then this HIF-2
inhibitor, PT-2399. And as you can see, it caused
significant regression.So these experiments were done in a large
cohort of mice, so 267 mice from
22 independently derived tumor graph lines, most of
them from clear cell renal cell carcinoma tumors.
And we found that overall, compared to sunitinib, this HIF-2
inhibitor resulted in greater tumor regression,
and in addition, was better tolerated.
You can see here that the mice treated with sunitinib lost weight, whereas the mice
treated with PT-2399 did not. And in the clinic we often see that sunitinib is
associated with diarrhea and loss of appetite and other problems.
So this data set the foundation for a multi-institutional phase
one clinical trial that Brian participated in.
And I'm just going to show you one piece of data.
So this, you can see here the famous plot, about 50 patients or so,
of course, heavily pre-treated patients.
And you can see that approximately 20% of the patients or so were on
treatment for over a year.
There was one complete response and six partial responses.
So this suggested that this drug was going to be active, and it was very well
tolerated. In fact, it went up to 1,800 milligrams twice
daily. If you have that much Tylenol, you probably kill yourself.
So in a companion study, we performed biopsies from
patients pre-treatment and on treatment, and this is a proximity ligation assay.
And as you can see that on the on-treatment biopsies, there is a reduction of these
red dots, which are HIF-2 complexes.
This is quantitated here, and by gene expression analysis, we could see that there
is a decrease in the HIF-2 gene expression program.
Peloton made the observation that there was a group of patients here in red that
had lower levels of the PT-2385, and that this
correlated with worse progression-free survival.
So they thought that this might be the result of rapid
metabolism, and that led to development of
PT-2977,
which actually has better pharmacokinetic properties, has a slightly higher
affinity. But as you can see here, this is our studies in non-human
primates.
It has significantly better AUC.
So Peloton was acquired by Merck, who
renamed PT-2977 bel sutiban.
And I'm not going to go through this data because Eric is going to go into a lot of
detail, but this has revolutionized the treatment of
VHL patients.
The drug was approved by the FDA in 2021.
This is the first patient that I treated, a patient that had, as you can see
here, this cerebellar hemangioblastoma, including a large one that was
symptomatic with headaches, and a second one here.
And after a few months on treatment, she was doing remarkably better.
In fact, she started feeling quite well soon after the
start of the treatment.
And of course, you'll hear from Brian, this drug has also shown
improvements
in comparison to everolimus in sporadic
patients. But what I want to point out is that
30% of the patients have a primary progressive disease,
so it is important for us to try to devise strategies to
identify these patients. So the approach that we took
was ask how are these tumors in the mice different,
those that are sensitive from those that are resistant?
And what we found is that the tumors that were sensitive had significantly higher
levels of HIF-2 alpha than the tumors that were resistant here in red,
quantitated here by Western blot,
and that was also true at the mRNA
level, which I'm not showing here.
So this led us to hypothesize that HIF-2 alpha itself could be a
biomarker, a predictive biomarker of response.
So based on that, and the fact that
these drugs have several fluorine atoms, as you can see here, we
leverage our cyclotron to generate an F18
labeled version of PT-2385, and then we
tested it in mice. So we implanted mice with tumors that either
had low levels of HIF-2 alpha. You can see there is very little nuclear signal.
This is background staining. These high HIF-2 alpha expressing tumors
implanted in the left and the right respectively.
And when we do the pet analysis, you can see that we are able to
identify the HIF-2 alpha expressing tumor, which is consistent
with the high specificity of the drug.
But as you can also see here, the kinetics are actually very quick.
So this led us to submit an IND to the FDA, which
got approved, and we have a clinical trial ongoing with these
tracer in patients.
One of the concerns with targeted therapies is the development of resistance,
and we found that this was indeed the case.
So this is a patient of mine that I think he got treated
after five lines of therapy
and did quite well. But if you look at the skin lesion, even though there was no
resist progression, it started getting filled up, and he
consented to a protocol that we had, and we did biopsy of that
lesion, and we found at this position in the coding sequence of HIF-2 alpha
that there were two different peaks.
We were able to see the mutation also by next
generation sequencing, and if we compare the pre-treatment sample, the mutation
was not there. So this is a mutation that is in
fact, and this is data from
Friedun Gradstein had, is a mutation that is occurring.
It's actually filling up the pocket that is bound by the drug.
And indeed, when we do this proximity ligation assays, we find that in
contrast to
pre-resistant samples,
then HIF-2 complex numbers remain the same,
and we can see that there is reactivation of the HIF-2 alpha
gene expression program in these resistant tumors.
Interestingly enough, the resistance mutations had been previously
identified in tumor graphs.
So we had had, I'm showing you data here for a tumor graph line
XP164 that was sensitive to different mice.
And after treatment for about six months, you can see that these tumors were
growing quite substantially. In immunoprecipitation experiments, we could
show that the HIF-2 complex, which was
dissociatedpre-resistant and
reformed in these two tumors, and we found the same
mutation that we later found in patients.
In addition, we found a second mutation in HIF1 beta, this
phenylalanine to leucine mutation, which is at the surface between
HIF1 beta and HIF2 alpha, and it increases the affinity
of the dimer.
There have been a number of other small molecule HIF2 alpha inhibitors
that target the same pocket. Some of them are no longer in
development, but some of them are.
Casat gefan, for example, BPI, it's
an inhibitor developed in China.
And this NIKAN compound, I don't think is being developed in the US anymore.
The only one that I'm aware of that has activity against the
resistant mutants is the NIKAN compound.
And of course, at this meeting, we have heard about
NEO811, which is this ARNT
degrader, which would be expected to have activity against both
wild type and mutant, although they did not speak
about the HIF1 beta mutation, so that's less clear.
Now, for us, this led us to try to develop second generation inhibitors.
And I partnered with a company, Aroha Pharmaceuticals, who developed a first
generation and then a second generation
siRNAs. So this is a double-stranded RNA that
binds the HIF2 alpha transcript and is linked to a
targeting moiety that recognize integrin alpha beta 3 and alpha
beta 5 on kidney cancer cells. And we could show that this
siRNA was able to effectively down-regulate not only wild type,
but also mutant HIF2 alpha in cells in culture.
So we tested this siRNA in
mice implanted with tumor grafts that were dependent on HIF 2 and that expressed
the integrins on the cell surface. Just going to show you here one example.
This was a very aggressive tumor. As you can see over the course of three weeks,
the tumor was growing very significantly.
This is an orthotopic implantation.
And then with the siRNA, the growth was
significantly attenuated. You can see this here
assessed by MRI, and then here looking at actual
tumor volume.
By immunohistochemistry, we could see that there was profound suppression of HIF
2 alpha protein, and this is quantitated here in this western blot, which
is intentionally overexposed so that you can see that there
is some residual but not very much HIF 2 alpha.
There was profound suppression of human VEGF in the mouse, and of course, the only
source of human VEGF is the tumor. So we did these
experiments in about half a dozen tumor grafts, and this provided a proof of
principle for this siRNA therapy and set the foundation for this phase
one clinical trial
which in my view provides a proof of concept.
This, as the other phase one clinical trial, in most phase one clinical trials,
this was a dose escalation trial with a three plus three design, three
different cohorts. And as you can see in this waterfall
plot, there were only two partial responses.
But we are looking for tumors that are both HIF 2-dependent and then that express
the integrins, and this was an unselected patient population.
I'm going to show you a case study. This was a patient of mine
with paraneoplastic polycythemia, so someone that we thought would have
HIF 2-dependent biology.
The patient got only two doses of the siRNA because
she had an acute coronary syndrome afterwards and came off a
study.
During the two-week washout period, and I could ask Eric and Brian
whether they've seen something like this, they probably haven't.
Tremendous progression within two weeks, somebody that had very aggressive
disease. And then when treated with siRNA, you can see here
after two doses that there was a persistent
decrease in this target lesion. And as you can see
here quantitated, and then suppression of the erythropoietin,
which lasted for months. On biopsy, we could see that there was a HIF 2
depletion, and we took a sample from the patient, and we implanted
into a mouse, and we did the same trial in the mouse, and we could
also see suppression of tumor growth and decrease HIF 2 alpha expression.
So to me, this provides a proof of principle for successful
siRNA targeting of HIF 2 alpha in patients.
We've taken a second approach. So there was some toxicity from the
siRNA.
And we've been working with somebody at UT Southwestern, and this is
using lipid nanoparticles, and
I don't have much time to go over that, but this is published.
In the last few minutes, I'm going to tell you about a recent story which
implicates HIF 2 in the regulation of
PTHrP, which is a critical mediator of
paraneoplastic hypercalcemia. I'm going to show you that HIF 2
induces the expression of PTHrP
and is responsible for paraneoplastic
hypercalcemia in a subset of patients.
And of course, this is not only a poor prognostic factor, but something that
untreated can cause significant problems in patients.
So we're going to use this tumor graft platform.
As I mentioned, we have a lot of patient samples, so despite the fact
hypercalcemia occurs in up to 10% of the patients or so, we were able
to identify about a dozen or so tumors that cause
hypercalcemia, and then we're going to be treating them with this HIF 2 inhibitor,
and then we're going to monitor them.
So here you can see the cohort. I think this is nine
tumor grafts, and in green are the ones where you can see that there was
substantial downregulation of the calcium.
This is quantitated here, so this was
highly statistically significant.
And you can also look at the PTHrP protein, which tends to
correlate with a reduction in calcium levels.
And again, this is also downregulated for the cohort.
There were three tumor graft bearing mice where
we saw less of an impact, in some cases, no impact at all
on the calcium levels or
PTHrP.We found
that this improvement in hypercalcemia was associated with better
mobility scores
in the mice gain weight, and as expected, there was
reduced dystrophic calcification and renal
injury. So these are all improvements associated with the
lower calcium levels.
Interestingly, in these mice where we saw
control of the calcium, in the majority of them, we saw a reduction in
tumor volume.
And indeed, if we take all of the mice that we have been treated
with HIF-2 inhibitors, and we compare the normal calcemic with the
hypercalcemic mice, and here you're looking at the reduction
in tumor volume, the percentage responsiveness rather.
You can see that in normal calcemia maybe the percentage is about 50%
or so where we see some level of responsiveness, but this is significantly
higher in the hypercalcemia, suggesting the hypercalcemia could be a predicted
biomarker.
Now, one of the things that happens when you treat with effective drugs is that
you're going to have control of paraneoplastic syndromes.
So we asked the question, how quickly could we see an effect?
And at four days, we don't see any change in the number of tumor cells as assessed
by tumor volume, but we could already see very profound down-regulation
of PTHrP. In keeping with the notion that this was
not an indirect effect from tumor regression, but rather a
direct effect.
And you can see that even within four days, we can see down-regulation of
calcium levels.
I mentioned before that HIF-2 alpha may be a biomarker, and when we perform
immunohistochemistry, we found that HIF-2 alpha levels were
substantially higher in tumors that tend to be hypercalcemic compared to
tumors that are normal calcemic. And this is evaluating both a tumor graph
microarray as well as individual slides.
So we wanted to understand what these tumors look like in patients,
and we focused on patients that had
primary tumors in place, had an elevated calcium that then
normalized after a nephrectomy, and we identified 26 such
patients. These are patients that did not have elevated PTH or
bone metastasis, which could be confounding factors.
And what we found, as in the tumor graphs, that the vast majority were
of clear cell histology.
They were also, interestingly, of high grade, so the vast majority were
Grade 3 or Grade 4, and 50% of them were either
sarcomatoid, rhabdoid, or both.
So these are features typical of very aggressive
kidney cancer. Interestingly, even in the sarcomatoid tumors
that were hypercalcemic, we could see high levels of HIF-2 alpha.
Now, one question that people ask sometimes is how is it that not all of
the tumors that are HIF-2 dependent have hypercalcemia?
And indeed, we know that VHL patients will rarely have hypercalcemia, and most of
them are responsive when you treat them with a HIF-2 inhibitor.
And what we found,
but before I go there, I'm going to show you that HIF-2 directly binds to the
promoter sequences, induces the expression of our reporter.
You can see this data here. So if we treat with a HIF-2
inhibitor, a luciferase expressed downstream of the
PTHrP promoter sequences, you can see down-regulation,
and in cheap assays we can see decreased binding to HIF-2.
Now on to what I was saying. So when we did whole genome ATAC
sequencing, and we found that in the hypercalcemic lines, not just the
promoter, but the whole PTHLH gene, which encodes
PTHrP, had open chromatin. And if we look at tumors
that are not hypercalcemic, and most of them are responsive to the HIF-2
inhibitor, you can see that this locus is not open.
Now, if we look at other canonical targets of HIF-2, you can see that
they are open in both the hypercalcemic as well as the
normal calcemic tumor, suggesting that one reason why some tumors
may have paraneoplastic hypercalcemia is because the PTHLH locus is
accessible for HIF-2 dependent transcription.
We also asked what happens to the locus when you treat with a HIF-2
inhibitor. And what we found is that when, and
here in red are the HIF-2 inhibitor treated tumor graphs,
you can see that there is not much difference either in the promoter
or in the coding sequences
when you treat with a HIF-2 inhibitor.
In contrast, we had two lines that had paraneoplastic
polycythemia, and when we look at the EPO gene, you
can see that there is decreased accessibility when you treat with a HIF-2
inhibitor in keeping with the idea that HIF-2 in this context
is functioning as a pioneering transcription factor, but not in the
context of PTHLH. And I don't know that there are other examples of this, but
this suggests that there is a context dependency to the idea of being a
pioneer transcription factor.
We had the opportunity to test this concept prospectively in a couple of patients.
It's a patient of mine that had sarcomatoid clear cell renal cell carcinoma, that
had hypercalcemia, that had progressed on prior therapy and was
treated with bel sutifan. And as you can see here, in less than two weeks,
we corrected hypercalcemia, and there was a profound down-regulation of PTHrP.
And this is data from a patient that had been treated with zoledronate, but the
point I'm making is that when the patient got bel sutifan, you can see that the
PTHrP became normalized within two days.
Although at two days, we are not seeing a significant drop in calcium levels, which
is approaching normal levels.
Just to point out that there was a second study from Bill Kaelin's group,
looking at the same concept,
but with an emphasis on PTHrP mediated effects on
cachexia, which was presented here.All right.
I'm a little bit over time, so I'm going to skip the
conclusions. Suffice to say that this is an exciting academic story,
going from the discovery of a gene to a first-in-class drug.
And I will just finish by acknowledging the people.
So these are the people in my group.
I originally led the hypercalcemia study.
Alaina is our biostatistician, Vanina manages our tumor graph platform,
and Bing was the bioinformatician involved in the study as well.
Kevin was the lead author of the Phase 1 clinical trial.
We worked very closely with Payal and our radiologist.
These are other UT Southwestern collaborators.
Really emphasize Rick Brewik, Kevin Gardner, and Steve
McKnight, who play critical roles in this.
These are the clinical teams. So this is the PT-2385 Phase 1
team with Brian, and this is the Aro-HIF2 team.
So thank you for your attention.
Thanks, Jim. That was a great journey through a few decades of HIF biology.
Congrats to the UT Southwestern team.
We maybe just have a minute for questions, and I just wanted to ask.
So you presented the work on the HIF-2 binding pocket mutation.
Is there other data out there on other mutations, or have other people found
the same mutations? I'm not aware of other data on the
mechanism of resistance.
Right.
To my knowledge, it remains the only data available.
Okay.
NeoMorphe was also referring to it in their presentations.
Yeah.
So you have the pocket mutation and then the mutation in HIF1-beta-
Yeah
... which is functioning as a second side suppression mutation.
Yeah. I think given how much we're going to be using the drug clinically, that Eric
and I will talk about, it's a pressing need for the field.
Yeah.
Eric, did you-- Oh, go ahead.
Please.
Hi, Eric Lightcap, Hyriscel.
I was intrigued by your data around the EPO
promoter.
As you know, belzutifan over time has a fairly
dramatic reduction in erythropoietin circulating levels, and then
that recovers over time. Is there any evidence that this
promoter effect is playing a role there?
Great question. So I think that remains, as far as I know,
enigmatic.
All right.
What triggers the re-expression of
EPO over time?
I understand from talking to the ARCOS folks
that they believe that's not the case for castatifan-
Mm-hmm
... which I'm a little surprised about. I would like to see the data long term.
But you're totally right. In the clinic, what we typically see is that there is
profound suppression of EPO with anemia, but then over time, there is
improvement, and the mechanism is not clear.
We could try to model it in the mice.
Obviously, trying to address that in patients may not be
straightforward, trying to get to the EPO-producing cells of the kidney
and asking questions about chromatin accessibility and so on.
But it suggests that there is another mechanism independent of
HIF-2 that induces EPO after a
prolonged period.
All right. Thanks.
Do one more from Eric.
Yeah, quick question about the PET imaging.
So one would imagine that mutations in the pASB
binding domain could be recognizable then in humans with this.
What experience do you have, and how granular is this?
Because I would imagine you could even look at subclonal evolution in a tumor.
Right.
The PET imaging is really exciting because I
think potentially it would allow us to look at HIF-2 alpha in
real time in patients, and not just at one time point, but potentially different
time points. And you're totally right, patients that develop the pocket
mutation, you would expect that you would see the lesion at
baseline take up the tracer, but then after the mutation occurs, the tracer would
not be taken up anymore.
Excuse me.
And of course, if we were to develop the graders or the siRNA therapy,
you would expect also to be able to look at the impact on the presence of
HIF-2 alpha.
Right. So,
in the experiments, and this paper is already submitted for publication, the
experiments we've done in the mice, the correlation with HIF-2 alpha levels
is very nice. We have not tested, however, tumors with
a mutation. I would expect that there would not be binding, but we
haven't formally done it.
We can do one more.
Hi. Thank you for the nice talk.
In addition to the mutation drive and the
resistance, have you ever observed the acquired
non-mutated induced resistance of
belzutifan?
Thank you. So, like you point out, this is an acquired mutation.
We don't see it in the pre-treatment sample.
It's possible that it will be present at very small amounts and
beyond the level of detection. So we think that there are two different
mechanisms. Right? So that is, we expect to see these mutations
in tumors that are initially sensitive but then become resistant,
but we don't think that these mutations account for innate
resistance from the get-go. We think that that represents different biology,
tumors that for reasons we don't understand appear to be resistant.
And one thing that will emerge from the presentations by my colleagues is that
you will see in VHL patients, response rates
exceed 70%, whereas in the sporadic setting, it's about 23%. Right?
So there is something that we don't understand about HIF-2
dependency. So HIF-2 dependency for VHL tumors is very high, for
sporadic tumors is less. But I expect that those tumors that are resistant from the
get-go is not because of mutations in the HIF-2 pocket, but rather
independency of HIF-2.
Thanks, Jim. Thanks. That was a great talk. Appreciate it.
All right, next up, Eric Jonash from MD Anderson is going to take us through the
clinical data of HIF inhibition in VHL syndrome.
Great talk. Hard act to follow.
Thanks, all, for being here. And as the slides are being pulled
up here, or maybe I need to do it myself
It's trying to load the presentations.
Just click Start by your name.
Okay, there we go.
Or no.
It looks like it's loading here.
There we go.
Yeah. So
you've heard how this has happened in terms of the clinical
development. I wanted to take a step back after showing my disclosures
here. And this has really been a clinical as well as a
research journey for over a century now.
And a lot of this really has been driven by VHL disease, the
VHL disease patients, and their
families. And so we have, over a century ago
now, Eugen von Hippel and Arvid Lindau, who made
observations in the eyes, hereditary lesions in the eyes of
humans and in the brains of humans, and this resulted in the
coining of von Hippel-Lindau disease.
And it took until 1993 for the VHL gene to be
discovered. And the other really important thing that happened in
1993 was what they then called the
VHL Family Alliance was also formed by three women, Joyce
Graff, Susan Warnick, and Peggy Marshall.
And I think it's really with that organization,
as well as the amazing scientists who
got the Nobel Prize for physiology or medicine in
2019, that we've gotten to where we have.
And I can tell you that the clinical trial that I'm going to be talking to you
about also was driven very much with the help of the
VHL Family Alliance. So as we think about rare diseases and not so rare
diseases, it's really this partnership between pharmaceutical companies,
between academicians, as well as the patients and the families who, where this is
their lived experience, and this is the disease that they're living with.
It's with that type of a partnership that we can make the most progress.
You've heard this already, broken VHL, too much HIF,
2A
that's oncogenic and results in various ways, I think that
are still somewhat inscrutable to development of
oncogenesis.
And from a clinical perspective, the question then is really
how can we block the consequences of VHL loss?
A very simple schematic here, where you have blood vessels on the bottom, and you
have the tumor cells on top, and you can have secreted factors that are in
between. And where can we actually interact with
this? In the first place, obviously, is going to be at the level
with the hypothesis that the main driver of
the microenvironmental development is because of aberrant
secretion of things like VEGF receptors that
result in a highly angiogenic tumor, and that by blocking the downstream
consequences of that, that we might be able to have a salutary effect.
The second is the ligand itself, VEGF.
And as you heard beautifully presented just before, getting a
little bit more proximal and hitting
the immediate consequence of VHL loss, which would be upregulation of
HIF-2A, being able to interact with that would make a lot of sense.
And the Holy Grail, and we do not have this in 2026,
would be to be able to actually fix broken VHL, and this would be gene therapy
or ways that you can actually normalize, especially if you have a point
mutated VHL. Oftentimes, this is because of
instability of that particular protein, and if you can restabilize it,
it still has residual functionality.
You might actually be able to
develop a situation where you can then get more out of
that VHL mutated protein.
So we're going to focus on HIF-2A inhibitors here in terms of their clinical
development. And as you've heard already, again,
how is this working? Well, we know that you have downregulation of
VHL function. You
do not get proteasomal degradation of HIF-2A.
It'll heterodimerize with HIF-1B.
You come in with an agent that can then block that
interaction, and you're going to get less downstream transcription.
One of the things that's really important from a clinician's perspective is that
these agents work quite differently from VEGF receptor
inhibitors. And one of the things that we see in patients is that
whereas with a VEGF receptor inhibitor, we see high blood
pressure, we see a variety of other things.
We typically don't see these in patients who receive HIF-2A
inhibitors. And to the degree that I don't fully understand why, because you would
expect by downregulating VEGF that you would get
similar types of toxicities, but you don't.
The other thing, of course, is that by blocking HIF-2A transcription,
there's some amazing
review articles from people like Celeste Simon that--
There's one, it's called "Sibling Rivalry," which maps
out and summarizes the dozens, if not maybe hundreds of
client genes that are regulated by HIF-2A.
We heard an interesting new one from Jim Berggoll is
here. And the question really is: How is this
affecting tumor cell autonomous function differently
from a pure VEGF receptor inhibitor?
And the answer is obviously in many, many different ways.
So for individuals who live with VHL disease, and I don't have a picture of what
VHL disease is for those who don't treat these patients, but this is a germline
mutation individuals
inherited an autosomal dominant fashion, and they
can get involvement of multiple different organ systems.
And that's also a really curious thing.
They lose one copy of VHL in their entire
body.unless they're mosaic and we get
retinal, cerebellar, and spinal hemangioblastomas.
These are benign lesions. We get endolymphatic sac
tumors of the middle ear, which again, are relatively benign lesions.
You get pheochromocytomas in the adrenal glands.
You get pancreatic cysts and pancreatic neuroendocrine tumors,
that being the first cancer, that pancreatic neuroendocrine tumor, renal cysts,
renal cell carcinomas, multifocal bilateral, and round ligament or
epididymal cystadenomas. Why are we not getting things in the liver
and in the earlobe and in the
nose? We don't know. But it is something about the cell
of origin in these various organs that are
susceptible to monoallelic loss of VHL,
where we do see that in most cases, you will lose the second allele of
VHL, which then results in the phenotypes that you see in these
organ systems.
So these individuals we have, and I'm going to talk to you about the clinical
trial, a therapy now that does alter the
behavior of these lesions. But in
2026, we still are missing a number of different things.
One of them is we don't have a therapy that completely
eradicates these lesions and makes most of them go
away.
We don't have a therapy that's tolerable in all patients.
This is a well-tolerated drug, but it's not one that's tolerable
in all.
We don't know actually about the durability
response yet because this drug's only been in clinical trials
for the last eight years or so, and we hope that it's going to actually
have greater durability response, and as Brian Rini is going to describe,
in advanced renal cell carcinoma, the durability is okay, but it's not
great.
And what we really want is we want a therapy
that can also decrease the number of surgical procedures.
But in the VHL patients, as I say here, it is tolerable by the
majority of patients. It does seem to have some durability
response in VHL patients, and it does, as I'm going to show, have
the decrease in number of surgical procedures.
But we can't eradicate all of the lesions.
It's not tolerated by everyone, and we don't have that much data
yet. We're talking about a rare disease, and we need to have more data, talk about
how we're going to go about doing that.
And we don't understand why it's not working in a subset of individuals.
And the other thing that we have, and it's sort of frustrating, is that this
is a good agent, but how do we actually come up with
strategies to find other agents that can really complement it in
an optimal manner? And in 2026, neither in VHL
disease nor in advanced renal cell carcinoma do we have that.
So let's talk a little bit about what we do have in terms of clinical data.
This paper was published in 2021. It was a true
multinational effort.
You can see most of the players here.
And
what was really interesting about this study
was that it
is a single-arm study.
This was approved by the FDA, so we have a rare disease.
We have no prior therapies available.
And this was a single-arm, originally powered for 50
patients, 61-patient study. Individuals had to have
germline confirmed VHL disease. They had to have at
least one measurable renal cell carcinoma because that was what was
decided upon. That's going to be our target organ system, although
most had other lesions. And the objective response
rate in that target lesion was the primary outcome.
This was the best way we could come up with a design in
this rare disease. And because we didn't really have a comparator therapy, there
was no randomization. This was okay with the US FDA.
It was a big problem with the European EMA
and resulted in a multi-year delay in the approval of this.
And it now is approved in Europe, but it was very difficult to actually get it
approved in Europe because this was not a randomized study.
The other thing that we did, and this was not originally part of the plan, but a
number of investigators, we insisted on making sure
that image gathering, not only for the renal tumors, the
primary endpoint, but also for the hemangioblastomas and the
pancreatic neuroendocrine tumors be performed at the same level.
Basically, FDA grade image
acquisition in the other organ sites, just in case
we were seeing a response. Maybe we could use these data to leverage into
another study or a larger study to be able to then get approval in
these other organ systems. As I'm going to show you,
that wasn't even necessary. This trial was sufficient to get approval in multiple
organ systems. So serendipity is a real thing in clinical research, and being
prepared for this is, I think, something that we need to
just be aware of.
So this is now a five-year follow-up here.
It was presented
recently. And we have 61 treated patients, and
after this number of years of follow-up, we still have more
than half of the patients on treatment.
And we see that the reason that people discontinued, a relatively
small number of them had discontinued because of progressive disease.
Most of them was basically because of
tired fatigue of being on clinical trials.
It's difficult to actually stay on a clinical trial for a long period of
time. The baseline characteristics, again, remember, this is a rare
disorder,
hereditary, and individuals that we have in our
clinics are relatively youngYou can see the median age here is
41 years old. To clarify, none of these individuals have
metastatic disease per se. They have primary disease in their kidneys, and what
they get is they get multifocal lesions in their kidneys.
We need to operate on these as they exceed three centimeters in size.
They develop cerebellar and spinal hemangioblastomas, which if they exceed a
certain size, they need to be operated on.
So this is kind of the journey that these patients need to
follow. And what we're trying to do here is we're trying to basically shrink
these things down and perhaps decrease the number of
organs that need to be operated on.
So youngish patient population, 41 years old.
And interestingly, although all of them had to have renal cell carcinoma,
we can see that 80% of them had central nervous system hemangioblastomas,
and 33% of them had pancreatic neuroendocrine tumors,
and 23% of them also had retinal hemangioblastomas.
So just by virtue of the fact that it usually comes as a package
deal, there's fairly extensive involvement of other
organ systems.
Most of these individuals, again, on the top right here, see 97% of these
patients had had some kind of prior procedure.
By the time you get into your early 40s with this disease, you will have had a
kidney operation, you'll have had a brain operation or some sort of procedure.
So these are the data for the primary endpoint, which was
response in the renal cell carcinomas.
When the New England paper came out, the objective response rate there was
49%, and we can see here now with additional
years of follow-up, the objective response rate has increased to 70%.
So these are genomically, and if we-- Samrat
Rajak and others have sort of looked at these primary renal
cell carcinoma tumors. Whereas more advanced renal cell carcinomas, metastatic
renal cell carcinomas, you start seeing an increasingly large number of mutations
in PBRM1, BAP1, SETD2. These tumors tend to be
genomically somewhat more simple, have fewer of these secondary lethal
mutations, and are going to be probably more HIF dependent.
So we're seeing here an objective response rate of 70% now,
up to 11% now CRs. No PDs as best
response, which is very good for this patient population.
And you can see the very generous waterfall plot on the right.
If you then ask the question of, is there an effect on the
tumor size? So the tumors basically have to be at least one centimeter in size.
We didn't really want them to be more than three centimeters.
After three centimeters, the risk of developing metastatic disease starts
increasing, so we were sort of gating, trying to keep most of them below that.
There were a few that were larger than three centimeters, but you can see here that
the objective response rate as a function of size looks like it
was best in those tumors that were between two and three centimeters.
I don't think there's much to this.
I think it's just because we have small sample sizes here.
But we're seeing that regardless of the size, we're seeing reasonable
response rates of at least 50%.
And this was the real surprise now, is that in central nervous system
hemangioblastomas, and I've done now--
My group has done three other Phase II
clinical trials using Sunitinib, a TKI,
Pazopanib, another TKI, and Davatinib, and we
never saw more than by resist 4% objective response
rate in the central nervous system hemangioblastomas.
Here, we're seeing now with longer follow-up, a 50%
objective response rate in these hemangioblastomas, meaning minimum
30% shrinkage. And we can see that there are now a couple of CRs,
and we can see that relatively low progressive disease as best response.
This is game-changing for these patients because this is now-- And you
saw Jim Regorolis' image. You have individuals that are
coming in saying, "Well, when am I going to plan my surgery?" To now, the
majority of them, it's, "Oh, I don't need surgery now for a number of years."
Pancreatic neuroendocrine tumors were the most spectacular from an objective
response rate. Not a large number here, but we're seeing an objective response rate
of 90%, and it's not really a
waterfall anymore here. It's kind of a rectangle on the right in terms of
the magnitude of shrinkage that we're seeing in these
lesions. Again, from a molecular perspective, it's not entirely clear.
I mean, again, they're obviously VHL loss dependent. They're HIF dependent.
In terms of the genomics of these tumors, we have much less information on
them. The hemangioblastomas are basically only VHL
loss. They don't have any secondary driver mutation, so they're, I
guess,
kind of dumb, if you will, in terms of they're very dependent on that
HIF up-regulation. And they don't really have, because they don't have genomic
instability, they don't have a mechanism really to escape this,
the Belzutifan. Thankfully, we're also seeing with the pancreatic neuroendocrine
tumors relatively similar
dependence.
In retinal hemangioblastomas also, we saw a great response.
And in terms of
VHL subtypes, we have deletions and point mutations,
which are the two major types of
mutations that we see here. And we're seeing that as a function of deletion
versus point mutation. We're not seeing massive differences
here in the patient's response.
This has to be my favorite figure of all time.
And this was
just some back history. We had submitted this paper to New England Journal.
It got rejected, and we said, "Well, no, we're not going to
accept no." And we worked on the data and came up with ways to really demonstrate
what the clinical meaningfulness of these data were.
And this was what we came up with. We came up with a composite swimmer's
plot of each patient, and then each of these dots and
arrows and triangles you see here are the procedures that occurred
prior to initiation of therapy. And
we don't have the counter on the bottom, but it's about 20 procedures of these 61
patients per year leading up to the initiation
of Belzutifan. And then you can see that there'sDramatic decline.
Obviously, there's a little bit of observer or physician bias here in terms of what
we were doing for the patients, but we could see that this, I think, really is
a reflection of how this is impacting our patients' lives.
Far fewer procedures.
In terms of adverse events, anemia, and actually not that much
hypoxia. In the more advanced patients, older individuals, I think it's more of
an aging physiology thing. We do see hypoxia as a side effect,
but anemia is definitely an on-target effect that we
see. And we can see here that in terms of fatigue and anemia, these are the
two main side effects.
This is just a summary of the anemia here.
We're seeing that 93% had any
grade anemia, 13% had Grade 3 or higher anemia.
So not an extremely high number of
patients with anemia.
Management, we use erythropoiesis-stimulating agents.
A small number of individuals had to have transfusion.
But we also see a tachyphylaxis. So you see that the anemia, and we were just
talking about this before, you see that the anemia develops, but then it sort of
plateaus
with most individuals, whether or not you intervene.
So just a quick clinical case here.
We have an individual who starts with von Hippel-Lindau disease,
and this is an individual who has just a
couple of tiny hemangioblastomas and one renal mass.
This is not a person that I would actually put on belzutifan.
This is a person that you would operate on, you'd take that mass out, and they
probably won't need anything for the next 10 years.
You're sparing them a lifetime of systemic therapy.
But here's an individual who has multiple lesions, older, has
now acquired more lesions, multiple prior procedures,
growth in multiple organ sites. This is an ideal case.
So this individual starts on belzutifan.
And all patients, regardless of whether or not
they're VHL patients or not, we instruct
them to buy a pulse oximeter. You can get one for 15 bucks.
You do monthly CBCs.
This patient then develops a drop in
their oxygen level. You take a break, you lower the dose,
and usually you can keep the oxygen saturation
reasonable. They undergo restaging. They're found to be anemic.
You give them erythropoiesis-stimulating agent, and
usually they continue on. We've seen this now, and I've seen this now
in over 100 patients.
So what do we need next? We obviously have a drug that makes a difference.
We are not fixing everyone. What we need is we need more data,
and one of the things that we have now is we have an international data collection
consortium, where we are developing a denominator of individuals
with VHL disease, a lot of them on belzutifan, so we can start asking
longitudinal questions that go beyond the 61 patients on the clinical trial.
We need, I think, an explanation for the upfront and the acquired
resistance. Jim Brageras has covered this very nicely.
We need
agents that can synergize with HIF-2alpha inhibitors.
I would say the TKIs are doing a little bit.
They're not synergizing. I think there's additivity there.
We don't understand the biology well enough, I think, at this point in time to
really understand what else do we need to do for these
individuals at this point in time.
So I'll stop there.
This has obviously been the work of many basic scientists,
clinicians, the VHL Alliance, companies,
and it's been really fun to be part of this journey. Thank you.
Thanks, Eric. Congrats on all that. Maybe time for a question.
I'll ask you a question while I was going to the mic, because I have a actually a
patient I reviewed at tumor board this morning.
Young guy, been on belzu for years, had multiple kidney operations, now
has a growing lesion that's probably going to go to a radical nephrectomy.
But do you continue belzu in those patients?
He clearly had a lesion grow through,
but we don't know what it's doing perhaps to other lesions or preventing new
lesions. There's no other drug to give, and that's... Yeah.
Yeah. And we do see this. We see what I would call rogue lesions where you
have 10 lesions, one of them eventually starts
growing. You manage that lesion with some type of a procedure,
and then you continue on.
You continue with belzu.
Yeah. Because otherwise, the hemangioblastomas or whatever else, or the other renal
masses that are still sensitive would start growing.
Yeah.
Hello. Many thanks. I'm Benoit Busling from Belgium, uro-oncologist
involved in cancer treatment, kidney cancer treatment.
We have three patients with von Hippel-Lindau on
belzutifan, and one is a very interesting case because he
only has
retinoblastomas,
and
with a risk to become without seeing.
So we started belzutifan, thanks to the medical need program
recently. We will see what will happen with these lesions in his eyes.
Now, the problem that we face in Europe is not only the fact that
there was no control arm. The problem that we face is also
that the MSD coupled the reimbursement
from belzutifan in the von Hippel-Lindau
patients to the LightSpark 005. So they wanted
approval for both together. So this is taking time.
And another problem is to what extent are you sticking
to the inclusion criteria of the Phase II trial?
Because imagine that you have a patient with a lesion in the kidney of four
centimeters or five, but you cannot do surgery because he will
end up with dialysis, or technically it's impossible,
then he could not enter into the medical need program or not enter into the
reimbursement if you stick to this criteria.
Also, a patient who has only hemangioblastomas, which cannot
undergo surgery, but the kidney, no lesions, then he will
not enter in the program. So it's a bit more complicated.
They are struggling
which will be the inclusion criteria for the patients in the
reimbursement.And I think we cannot stick to the
inclusion criteria of the phase two study. Now, my question is the following.
Sorry, it's a bit long.
Imagine that you would have a patient with von Hippel-Lindau syndrome
with several lesions in the kidney, but maybe also in other
organs, and he has some metastasis.
Have you been treating these kinds of patients in your clinic?
And what did you see at the level of the metastasis?
Yeah. So individuals who develop metastatic disease,
they're very challenging. VHL disease, once it develops
metastatic disease from the kidney tumors, we find that they don't
respond quite the same way as sporadic
RCC patients.
We've been treating them upfront with
IO TKI combinations like cabozantinib, nivolumab,
lenvatinib, pembrolizumab.
A number of people, my colleagues, have tried treating these
individuals with ipilimumab, nivolumab alone, IO therapy alone,
and they don't respond particularly well.
The metastatic lesions, I also have several individuals who
develop metastatic disease. The metastatic lesions don't also
respond as well to belzutifan as you would like.
So there's something about, I'm not sure what exactly is
happening with these individuals.
Perhaps it's some sort of immune tolerance that makes immunotherapy more
challenging, and also as the
renal cell carcinoma is metastasized, they potentially become
a little bit more HIF-2alpha indifferent than in other
situations. So I think I would treat this individual
with an IO TKI.
You probably would not be able to get belzutifan in the frontline setting because
your EMA recommendations are going to be IO plus two
TKIs before you actually can get to belzutifan.
So I would probably treat this person with an IO TKI.
Okay. Many thanks. And I'm interested to participate to the database
collection if possible.
Okay. Absolutely.
Thanks, Eric.
So I'm going to bring us home with all the data about HIF inhibition in the
sporadic setting. I don't know if I introduced myself.
I'm Brian Ream. I'm a geo-medical oncologist at Vanderbilt.
This is just a random slide from one of the early
phase two studies in kidney cancer.
And what we saw was response rates from this drug as monotherapy,
again, in the 20-ish, maybe 25, 30% rate.
So it looked maybe not quite TKI-like for this drug in this setting, but there
was clear activity here. If those of you familiar with IMDC
classification, it's just a aggressiveness of tumor classification, didn't appear
that there was an obvious difference across IMDC risk categories.
No complete responses. You see a relatively limited number of patients with
progressive disease. We're going to see these numbers go up in the phase three OO5
study. The reason here is this was probably fourth, fifth
line of therapy, and for patients to get to that line of therapy, they need more
indolent disease. That's probably what is reflecting there.
So we presented the data. This is actually still not published yet, but we
presented these data at ESMO, boy, I guess it was 2024 maybe,
of the final analysis of Lightspark-005.
Initial publication in New England Journal, and these were the follow-up data
looking at overall survival. So as has been alluded
to, this was a refractory kidney cancer population, one to
three prior regimens. They had to have immune therapy, and they had to have at
least one VEGF TKI, which again, are the standard therapies
for this disease. Seven hundred and fifty patients randomized equally to belzu,
120, which is the standard daily dose, or everolimus, which I would
call an old standard of care.
You could probably criticize the control arm of this trial, but nonetheless, it was
a standard of care at the time this trial was designed, which was a really long
time ago. PFS and OS is dual primaries.
So these are the updated PFS curves, and I would say a couple things that you see
here if my cursor works. So there's no difference in the median, right?
Five and a half months median. That's about what you get with TKIs in this setting,
six months, something like that for an average median PFS.
So about the same median. And you see these curves really
overlapping for the first six months, obviously accounting for that identical
median. But then you start to see a separation, and this is a theme we're going to
see with the other PFS curves that I'm going to show you in the adjuvant setting
and in combination in the refractory setting, that there seems to be a
tail-of-the-curve effect of belzu across multiple indications.
I didn't appreciate it as much when I first saw this data set, but with the newer
ones, I think we're appreciating it more.
And you can see nearly 20% of patients still progression free at two years.
That's a long time for refractory kidney cancer.
So there's clearly a subpopulation of patients, we don't yet know how to identify
them, that has a long and durable effect.
Not as long and durable as in the VHL syndrome patients, but these are
the best patients I have in my clinic.
They're on a monotherapy that's really well-tolerated with disease control now
measured in years. It doesn't get better than that in this refractory setting.
These are the OS curves. There was not an overall survival difference.
You see the curves, again, start to split a little later until you get to the
censoring. Hazard ratio below one, but a non-significant P value.
And belzu to date has not shown a survival advantage in any setting,
and not much has shown a survival advantage in the refractory setting in fairness.
These are the response data. So if you look on the left-hand side, there's that
response rate of 23%. So again, almost identical
to the phase two. That's actually decent.
Usually, you see the numbers go down in a phase three setting.
There was a small percentage of patients who had CRs, and this has been
seen, I would call it,
this is not a play on words, sporadically across these trials where we see maybe a
little bit of CR. So you can see it. I've seen it clinically, but it's not terribly
common. But as
we heard, the PD rate for monotherapy is quite high.
A third of patients will have primary progression, and that's a problem in
refractory kidney cancer when patients have often bulky and sometimes symptomatic
disease.And again, we don't yet know the
mechanism there. And one thing I tell patients from the start is, "Listen, this is
not a quick-acting drug." So I don't have
data about time to response, but it's often not at that first three-month scan.
It may be at a six or nine-month scan.
So for whatever reason, the kinetics of response are different with this
drug. On the right is the duration of response, and this is a reflection of what
I tried to point out in the PFS
graph, is that you see a longer duration, a longer tail of the curve with
belzutifan. Obviously, not many everolimus responders.
But patients who are in that 15, 20-ish percent who
do respond tend to do so quite durably.
This is a slide, I combined two slides together about time to first
onset, this middle part here, and then duration of some of the common side effects,
and Eric alluded to this. Anemia, an on-target side effect, super common.
I think almost everybody gets some degree of hemoglobin drop, and it obviously
depends on where they start. All the side effects pretty much occur early.
So it's the kind of drug maybe different than other things we do, where you sort of
know almost within the first weeks what you're in for.
The hypoxia is super early, I would say within days to weeks.
Anemia may be over many weeks to a couple of months, et cetera, as you see listed
here, but generally within a month or two.
We see this weight increase, which is a real thing, and I think is a reflection of
what Jim talked about in the HIF-2 cachexia link, et cetera, but it's a
real thing. And then on the far right is the average duration.
You can see there's huge ranges here.
Over many, many months, if not years.
But if you just look at the median. Duration of anemia is also a
function of how aggressive you are in managing it with erythroid-stimulating
agents. But you can see the other durations here.
So it's a very different side effect profile than our multi-targeted TKIs, which is
a good thing. Some unique side effects.
I think there's been a big learning curve from the VHL syndrome
days to the early belzu monotherapy.
I think it's now been around enough that I think comfort in managing these side
effects has increased tremendously, certainly in the academic setting, probably not
yet in the community setting.
So that was the data for approval. It's approved as
monotherapy in a refractory setting in the US. I commonly use it third line.
I give IO TKI frontline. I usually give TKI monotherapy second line, and then
belzu is probably my go-to third-line drug.
I'm sure we all use it differently in this setting.
So then there were two important data sets just presented at ASCO GU a couple of
months ago. The first was the 011 study.
This is now in a similar refractory setting as 005, but now it's in
combination with lenvatinib, a multi-targeted TKI,
compared to cabozantinib, which was,
and still is, a standard of care in this setting.
Cabo monotherapy, it's just the way--
where drugs end up is also a function of how drug development proceeds, which is
sometimes a bit random. But cabo is a really well-established second-line drug
and had not been beaten in multiple studies.
So it was the right comparator. Again, 750 patients.
You could see with that highlighted bullet points that they had to have
failed prior immune therapy, and many had prior TKIs, as again, is common.
Len-belzu at standard doses versus cabo, PFS and OS, so very standard
Phase III design.
This is the
PFS primary endpoint, and again, you see some of the shape here
is similar to 005. You see some overlap up front.
Here you do see a difference in the median of about four months, and you
see the hazard ratio of 0.7, so a significant
difference in PFS. These lenva and cabo
are not identical TKIs, but there's no real reason to believe that lenva is
much better than cabo. I don't know that that's a thing. We could talk about it.
So it's really, obviously, what is belzutifan adding in this setting?
I put this blue arrow because you see, again, this is sort of when I first saw
these data, I said, "Gee, it's not just a difference in the median and hazard
ratio." You're starting to see this tail of the curve and a doubling at two years.
Again, a refractory setting, a third of patients still progression-free at two
years. That's pretty good.
You're throwing a TKI in here early to give the disease control, but I think
the durability, at least in part, comes from the belzutifan.
Again, no difference in OS. I think this was a more promising signal than we saw in
005. You remember that hazard ratio at the final was 0.92.
This is 0.85 at the initial analysis.
I'm not remembering the median follow-up. I think it was about two years.
Looked like minimum follow-up when the censoring starts is about 16 to 18 months.
So we'll see how this story plays out.
Refractory kidney cancer has been a very difficult setting to show an overall
survival benefit. I think there's a lot of debate now.
It's not yet approved, but it will be. Where are we going to use this?
Do we really want to couple belzutifan, which is a wonderfully tolerated
monotherapy with lenvatinib, which is, in my opinion, the worst-tolerated TKI?
So I think there's a lot of discussion, and we can get into it, and
we'll see how it plays out, but no doubt a useful regimen.
And I think we're seeing additive effects, and I think Eric mentioned this.
This is not synergy. It's probably sub-additive, actually.
Response rate, again, we do see some CRs, a small number.
Remember, with belzu monotherapy, it was 34% primary PD.
Now it's 5%. So TKIs are really good at controlling tumors and
really good at shrinking tumors. They're really good also at beating patients up,
but they're really good at disease control up front.
So that's probably one of the biggest advantages here.
Again, if you have a refractory patient with bulky symptomatic disease, I'd be a
little nervous about belzu monotherapy.
I
would not be nervous about a TKI-containing regimen.
Again, duration of response, same thing.
We're seeing two-year duration of response, which is about what we see with the IO
TKI regimens. It's almost identical.
So a non-immune therapy containing regimen producing fairly durable
responses, I think is notable. And again, you see a doubling,
50% durability at two years.
And then the other big data set presented was LightSpark-022.
Merck basically put belzutifan in the water across every kidney
cancer
scenario and hits on almost all of them.
So this was presented. This is in the adjuvant setting where many of you know that
pembrolizumab monotherapy, which was the control arm of this trial, is the standard
of care from KEYNOTE-564 at high-risk resected kidney
cancer. This is now adding belzutifan.
I famously predicted this trial would be wildly negative.
I was absolutely wrong about that. You can't get them all right.
So this is basically the same criteria aspembro
monotherapy as the KEYNOTE-564 study.
Huge study, over 1,800 patients, year pembro, year
pembro/belzu, DFS as primary endpoint.
And so this is the initial DFS result showing a significant reduction in
the risk of recurrence in these patients.
Hazard ratio is 0.72. You could see about a 6% or
7% difference, and pembro versus placebo was about the same.
It was about a 7% or 8% difference at similar time points and follow-up.
So, another notch of benefit here.
You see median follow-up over two years. This is early.
Kidney cancer patients, even high risk, take five to six years to recur on average,
so this is really early, but obviously these curves split early and stay split,
until we get up to the censoring.
But no difference in OS. Again, this hazard ratio is fairly
low. I'm no statistician. When I look at these curves, I don't know where
the .78 comes from. Somebody needs to explain that to me, but the data's the data,
but really early time point for survival.
Hazard ratio below one, but, a huge confidence interval, non-significant at this
point. So we'll see. I think the feedback that
the way I feel and what I've sort of heard other experts say is that I think a lot
of people may wait for overall survival to give belzu in this setting.
I think it's different than immune therapy, and we can get into that debate.
But, nonetheless, a positive study that could change the standard of care or at
least provide another option in a subset of patients.
My biggest limitation in using this is the problem with
pembro monotherapy is half the patients won't recur anyway, right?
So even if you take high risk, half of those patients don't have cancer, they're
not going to recur, and you can only harm those patients with treatment.
Now you're doubling down on that, and you're giving them two drugs instead of one.
So it's kind of that balance of, am I willing to hurt this 50% more
to help an extra 6%, et cetera, and each doc and patient may make that decision
differently. This is the triplet study.
It's called 012. There was a press release two days ago I'll tell you about.
When I put these slides together, I didn't know the data was going to be out or the
press release, and so this was basically the final frontier of HIF inhibition.
This was an enormous frontline trial. This number's actually wrong.
It was over 1,800 patients. Len/pembro, ioTKI is
a standard of care in this setting, commonly used, and this was adding either
HIF inhibition to this investigative triplet or CTLA-4
inhibition to this. So basically testing almost every active mechanism in
kidney cancer and thinking, if one is good, two is better.
If two is better, three must be great, right?
That's how we do oncology drug development.
And I don't have a slide on this, but we just heard 48 hours ago that the study was
negative. Did not meet its primary endpoints for PFS or OS.
I have no idea why. There's going to be a huge autopsy, as you might imagine, and
HIF inhibition's already shown activity with lenva in that
011 study with pembro in 022 and basically every setting.
So it's really unclear to me biologically or otherwise what went on, but
we will find out. We'll certainly be talking about it a lot.
And this is a table that just puts all the data on one slide, and it goes from
left to right, from adjuvant frontline and then to the refractory settings.
You could see there's, again, different partners, et cetera, so it's a little bit
apples and oranges, but just to put all the numbers. This is that 012 frontline.
We don't have the data yet, but now know it's negative.
I hadn't put a table like this together before, but you see
relatively consistent effects. Again, different settings.
One's DFS, one's PFS, so I get that, but relatively consistent effect.
Again, notwithstanding the 012 results.
Non-significant overall survival, although two of these studies are pretty early.
We may or may not see that mature, et cetera.
And again, that primary PD rate, which as monotherapy is higher, but in
combo is much lower. So clearly an active approach across
multiple kidney cancer settings.
And then I just wanted to say one word about biomarkers before I finish up.
This is a poster that Merck presented again at ASCO GU.
We're just starting to get some biomarker data.
HIF inhibition, as you heard Jim and Eric talk about, it's ripe for
biomarker development. This is different than our very messy TKIs, which act on the
stroma. This is a tumor-targeted therapy and very focused.
So, Merck looked across-- this was a dose
escalation study, which I didn't talk about.
They tested, I think it was 120 daily and 200 daily.
Didn't turn out there was much difference, but they used this as an initial attempt
to look at biomarkers. And this table really just looks at
immunohistochemistry and gene expression scores across-- these are various Merck
proprietary collections of genes that they've used across their solid tumor
program. The bold is where there was significant associations with the various
clinical outcomes. So small study, hypothesis generating.
It is corrected for multiple testing, but still, I think a very initial sort of
foray, and these same markers will be looked at in 005 and other studies, I
imagine. So we're starting to get some hints of what might be important.
What's down here, they also looked at DNA alterations.
They looked at BAP1, which Jim has described very well, and it looked like BAP1
mutants had a better response to belzutifan.
Jim, I would love your thoughts about why that could be the case.
I would think it would be the opposite, so I don't know if this is a totally
spurious finding, but it's not an insignificant number of patients, right?
It's a decent number. So I just put it on there because it's something I don't
understand, and I think this field is just starting.
You heard Jim allude to, or maybe Eric as well, CASGADAtifan is made by a company
called Arcus. It's the other clinically advanced
HIF inhibitor in kidney cancer. It's not yet FDA approved.
I think they presented some data here as well,
and some of these slides came from them.
This was data presented at ASCO GU.
They have this study called ARC20, which has 10 different cohorts
now in various settings, in various combos, where they're just testing out what's
the activity. In the monotherapy cohort at what is now the
phase three dose of 100 daily, you see a response rate of 45%.
Small number of patients, but remember, that's about double what we saw with belzu
in a similar setting.All sorts of caveats to that statement.
We'll see how it holds up. There may or may not be some pharmacokinetic
advantages to this drug.
We also see a very low PD rate. Remember, it was 34% with Belzu,
although lower in the initial study.
So again, an interesting compound is always better to have more drugs in
a setting, at least from a clinical standpoint. Median PFS of 15 months.
So as these data have matured, they've become more and more impressive, and again,
some of the responses take a while to happen.
This is a study called Peak1, which is the registration study for
castadafam. This is
prior immune-exposed clear cell kidney cancer patients randomized to
either cabo alone, which as I told you is a standard of care, or castadafam plus
cabo. Looking at PFS, it's just open, starting to accrue.
And then my last couple slides are, I give this company a lot of credit for
doing some nice biomarker work with clinical development.
Usually it's all the clinical development and then we get to the biomarkers later.
They've done a nice job of incorporating biomarker development into their clinical
development. They've looked at serum IPAG in reduction.
That's what's on the left here, and this is a function of dose when they were still
playing around with dose. And then if you look at best
objective response by maximal serum IPAG and change, the
green is the responding patients, and you see them segregating a little more to the
right here. And so there is an association of deeper
IPAG reductions and a better chance of having an objective
response. All patients have some degree
of serum IPAG reduction, so it's deep versus less deep.
It's not that some patients don't have a reduction.
And this is just another way of basically saying the same thing, of looking at
serum IPAG and change now segregating it into the best objective response for these
recess categories, and you see these box and whisker plots go
down over time. And this on the right here is just the PFS data saying the same
thing. So this is obviously an on-treatment, right?
You don't know how deep somebody's going to suppress their IPAG before you start
treatment, so it's not a perfect predictive biomarker, but biologically, of course,
makes sense.
One thing they have looked at is tumor IPAG and mRNA expression, so this would be
a baseline biomarker if you had an available sample and looking at expression
as a function of what they call disease control, which people usually lump in
response and stable disease as disease control, which I don't love doing, but be
that as it may.
Again, I think these are early data, relatively small number of samples, but I
think biologically sensible, and I think we're going to have a
biomarker for HIF inhibition. We've spent 20 years trying to find one for
VEGF and 10 years for IO, and have failed miserably, but I think we will have one
for HIF inhibition.
We
have a trial called OPTIC, which is a biomarker-based study I won't talk about, but
we've looked at some HIF-2 gene expression.
There's different signatures out there, including
one that Jim's been involved with and other signatures that we've looked at.
In our hands, metastatic tumors exhibit increased HIF-2 signaling.
That's a good thing in the sense that if that's a marker for response, that
those are the patients we're treating in our clinic.
I don't have time to explain all our clusters, but cluster three and six comes from
a separate study, and it's these really biologically distinct tumors.
They're not angiogenic, they're not immune, they're something else.
And it was really interesting to us that they had the highest HIF signature scores.
I would have assumed that the angiogenic clusters would express HIF genes.
And I think why we're seeing additive effects clinically is because that's not the
case. So the biology of responding to angiogenic drugs and the biology of
responding to HIF drugs, I think is different.
Not entirely non-overlapping, but certainly not
entirely overlapping, and I think that's why we're seeing these broad clinical
effects.
We're about to embark on this study where we're going to do just a very small pilot
study looking at pre on treatment and progression biopsies,
and Jim, this is why I asked you the question about resistance.
So we hope to learn, looking at these gene expression changes
over time and really drill down on baseline predictors, looking at
mutations or other causes of resistance, et cetera.
This is still working its way through our system.
Hopefully by this summer we'll have this open.
So just to wrap up, HIF inhibition has clear activity across the spectrum of
kidney cancer. Why the frontline trial was negative, I have no idea, but we'll
figure that out in the next six months.
Exactly where to apply it, I think is something we're going to debate.
Is adjuvant the best? Is second line the best? Should it have a partner?
Do you want to save it for monotherapy?
I think we will be debating that for months, if not
years. And I'm really high on a lot of the early
biomarker work, right? Everybody stands up and talks about how we need
a biomarker. We've really not done great work in kidney cancer, not from
lack of trying, but lack of finding, but I think those are coming in kidney cancer.
So, thanks for your attention. I think we have a few minutes for any questions for
myself or the others.
Hi. Eric Lightcap again.
So I believe you had looked at KIM-1
as a biomarker for atezolizumab
and shown some association there.
Has there been much evaluation of
KIM-1 as a biomarker for HIF-2 alpha
inhibitors?
Yeah, it's a good question. I'm not aware of any data that's public
that's looked at that, but you can imagine it's on the list.
Yeah.
KIM-1, for those who don't know, kidney injury molecule 1.
There's some data in the adjuvant space in kidney cancer in a study
called IMmotion010 of atezolizumab, and now emerging some other advanced
spaces. It seems to be a marker of disease.
Right.
How much bulk of disease is there? It's more in metastatics, less in the adjuvant,
et cetera, and may be a marker of MRD in the adjuvant settings.
I
don't know if you are, Eric, or anybody.
I'm not aware of any data that's public around HIF inhibition,
but in the next year I'm sure there will be.
All right.
It's such an easy thing to measure. Everybody's looking at it.
Right.
Yeah.
All right.
Yeah. I think what's going to be interesting is that,
A, I think we know it's a marker of MRD.
B, I think the LightSpark 22 study is going to allow us to
understand better whether or not there's any association between the presence or
absence, and the probability of response to belzutifan, at least
in the adjuvant setting. So I think there's...
work that's being done, which is going to help us understand that, but there's
nothing currently available.
Any question?
Hi. Dan Crooks from the Neurologic Oncology Branch at
NCI.
And I suppose I could just go ask Ron this question, but
I'm curious.
We see the kidney tumors grow through belzutifan.
So question number one, do you think that there's
mechanisms other than genetic mechanisms that might be causing some of those tumors
to grow through belzutifan?
Question number two, I just don't know.
Do the other lesions ever grow through belzutifan, the DNA-
In VHL syndrome?
Yes, in VHL syndrome. Sorry. I'm purely speaking about that.
Yeah. So, your first question, I think the answer is we don't know,
but you could hypothesize that there might be some sort of microenvironmental
remodeling. We know that HIF-2 versus HIF-1 dependence
of immune subpopulations, they tend to be, I think, much more HIF-1
driven, but there's some variation as a function of which
subset we're talking about, and is that some way of actually engendering
resistance?
Good hypothesis. We don't have the clinical data yet to be able to answer
that. With regards to the lesion, so
how often do I see a hemangioblastoma that has responded starting
to grow back? It's relatively rare, but what I
am seeing now increasing, what we're seeing increasingly, is there's a subset of
people, once again, who get a rogue lesion where cyst formation
will occur while on belzutifan,
and it is something you need to keep an eye out for when you've got
patients on this. We have now... Well, Ian McCutcheon has
operated on several of these individuals.
We have those tumors, and we're in the process of doing spatial transcriptomic
analysis and genomic analysis to better understand what on earth
happened there. The first time I saw it, I was
like, "Oh, no big deal." But now we're on patient three
or four, so it's a real thing.
Just maybe one last question, Jim, I'm going to ask you this.
Is there a biologic reason you...
Let me think how to ask this question.
We're using HIF inhibition as monotherapy in combination in this setting and that
setting. Would you, from a molecular standpoint, say, "Boy, this is the setting
or the partner that makes the most sense"? If I ask that question right.
Yeah. The short answer is no. I think
the long answer is,
this has been really puzzling. I'll tell you that
I have this recollection after we had our original paper that I
talked about in the tumor graphs. We had some signals suggesting
that HIF-2 may be involved in regulating PTHrP at that time,
and
we saw some differences between the sensitive and the resistant, and then when we
were treating with inhibitors, it was down-regulated.
And I just assumed that HIF
biology was going to be linked to more indolent and angiogenic
disease.
Mm-hmm.
And now, when Bill reached
out to us, "Hey, we want to look at PTHrP in cachexia," and then
we revisit the data and said, "Okay, let's take a look at hypercalcemia." Was
very surprised the majority of our tumor graphs respond, and
as I recall, the majority are
sarcomatoid.
Yeah.
So you have the data in VHL
patients, I think, is unequivocal, right?
The majority of patients, you see some level of shrinkage, there is HIF-2
dependency there. In a sporadic setting, we are
seeing many fewer responses, and I think
there is data that in those tumors that we regard as particularly evolved
sarcomatoid, that they have lost angiogenesis.
One thing that characterizes sarcomatoid tumors is that they are very mesenchymal
and significant drop in blood vessels.
There is still some that have very significant HIF-2 alpha
expression, nuclear expression, and they are dependent on HIF-2.
So I think
that is something that is very intriguing.
Yeah.
And in terms of the partnership, I think
that the data with immunotherapy, as you know, initially there was this suggestion
from Bill that HIF-2 may be regulating HERBs, and there is additional
data from David. I don't know whether it's David Brown, or I don't know whether
it's published or not, suggesting that may not be so critical.
So I think it's still... And frankly, take a step back farther,
what's the role of HIF-1? That's also been controversial.
Right.
But certainly Neomorph, they presented
data with one of our tumor graphs that didn't have a good response to
the
PT2399,
that had low HIF-2 alpha and then high HIF-1 alpha, and it responded to
their drug. So they are hypothesizing, and certainly consistent with
our data, that there could be a subset of tumors that are actually HIF-1 driven.
Mm-hmm.
In our tumor graphs, the tumor graphs that tended
to be sensitive had high HIF-2 or low HIF-1, and the resistant the other
way around.
Yeah. There
have been some attempts at immune therapy plus HIF inhibition.
I think we're going to see more in the future.
We've not quite seen that story play out.
But anyway, thank you all for coming. Thanks to both of these excellent speakers.
I learned a lot in this session. I hope you all did as well.
So thank you for coming. Safe travels home.